hey guys I'm just 87th of every and
here's the exciting things that are
happening in video games today Nintendo
who said the switch could have better
third-party support than the way you did
during than tendo's investor Q&A
Nintendo director Shin Yeo Takahashi
explained that with previous Nintendo
consoles the focus was on proprietary
development tools saying they now plan
to change that up he said since the
start of Nintendo switch development
we've been aiming to realize an
environment in which a variety of
different third-party developers are
able to easily develop compatible
software such as by making it compatible
with unreal and unity as well as our own
development tools as a result even
companies with only a few developers
have already started making games for
nintendo switch adding nintendo will
keep on creating unique software by
doing so i believe we will encourage
third-party developers to create a
number of quality software titles for
nintendo switch Shigeru Miyamoto added
in the current development environment
I'd say it would take less than a year
for them to port a pc game to nintendo
switch next up xbox fans should be in
for a good year as Phil Spencer said
that 2017 is going to have more xbox one
console exclusive games than 2016 did
Spencer tweeted that he thinks it will
be a good year for the platform adding
that xbox one should have more first
party games than last year with great
diversity in 2016 xboxes console
exclusives included Gears of War for
quantum break recall and support this
year we're expecting crackdown 3 cuphead
state of decay 2 and C thieves finally
Bethesda has said fallout 4 is its most
successful game yep even more so than
Skyrim Bethesda marketing exec Pete
Hines told kind of funny on their game
cast fallout 4 has got to be the most
successful game we've ever launched in
our company's history more than Skyrim
in terms of what we did ok so it's not
immediately clear what hind means my
most successful but there's the quote
for you Skyrim released in November of
2011 and sold more than 20 million
copies as at one
14 while fallout 4 which came out in
November of 2015 shipped 12 million
copies on launch day unfortunately we
don't have any more recent sales figures
to go off regarding Bethesda's next
project Heinz added whether it's fallout
or elder scrolls or whatever they're
going to do next I think their mantra is
always we really got to step up our game
that is everything I've got for you
today do head to gain spot for stories
on ps4 bundles and FIFA 18 coming to
switch I will see you tomorrow